ciao rivers e benvenuti nuovissimo video
sono emozionatissima perché questa è la
prima puntata di un nuovo format che
spero tantissimo che vi piaccia nel
quale mi cimenterò in ogni puntata in un
mestiere diverso
sapete tutti quanti quanto io ami sushi
mi segue su instagram avrà visto un
sacco di storie in cui io sono a cena in
un ristorante di scorci quel ristorante
è lo yokohama ed è il ristorante della
mia amica rosi
ciao a tutti ragazzi allora oggi rosi
cosa farà mi insegnerà a preparare un
roll e sfateremo anche il mito che il
sushi man deve essere uomo chi ha detto
ci sono un sacco di donne come lei che
sono le regine del sushi
quindi oggi ger powers solo due donne in
cucina
eccoci qua siamo arrivate nella zona
sushi bar cosa facciamo adesso per prima
cosa io farei un roll proprio base in
modo tale che magari da casa possono
anche replicarlo in una macchia il
salmone avocado top prima cosa mettiamo
in quanto ok allora innanzitutto adoro
questa composizione ma ad ora un po meno
il fatto che non ho mai tagliato un
avocado e insegnare ovviamente sì
prendiamo l'avvocato key e il coltello
cosa facciamo ma vi vedo molto ha in
mano così ma non siamo un taglio non si
è in mezzo dell'avvocato ok e piano
piano
giriamo attorno facendo fare in giro
facciamo l'apertura con un twist leggero
top è un'ala allora il metodo più
semplice è questo vai dentro a queen
tipo scavo dentro scava l'abbiamo fatta
il primo step per fare un'ora macchia e
prendere l'alga nori posso certo devi
una cosa che ti voglio vedere il riso è
che ogni tanto mi capita di mangiare del
sushi con il riso un po tipo gommoso
colloso perché perché evidentemente
hanno stracotto il riso e questo come
come lei è cotto questo l'abbiamo lavato
a si lava pressi si lava per togliere la
prima sporcizia che c'è nel chicco di
riso fondamentale dopo la cottura e
versarlo nella bacinella di legno per
poi condirlo con aceto di riso e sa che
riso c'è avocado anche in italia ne è
fermo né almone allora vediamo il
salmone
ma che cos'è questa cosa questo è il
frigo sushi bar posso aprire io voglio
vedere ormai top quindi c'è tutto è
salmone prendere il pesce che ridarà
nessuno cavalieri il ciclo del freddo
quindi prendo il salmone
e chiude così prendiamo un mezzo pugno
di riso vari video si mette una palla di
neve lo poniamo al centro dell alga nori
e con delle leggere pressione ma lì
perché anche questo fa sì che il riso
non diventi ma posso ho quindi leggere
pressioni poetto seconda cosa che
facciamo è mettere il sesamo
mettiamo il sesamo sopravvivo cosa io
così tipo oggetto mari la nostra lega
nord con il riso la giriamo a cina si è
girata oddio plus tagliamo 3
striscioline stesse possono bastare mai
apre un roll si odia come si tagli
aspetta rai che non sempre le mani le
dita piegate perché se tutti mi le dita
così travagli i tagli mentre se le
pieghe così si beh non proprio così
leggere bravissima leggermente piegate
benissimo vai 1
perfetto il prossimo stretta è quello di
mettere il salmone al centro della
galanina nori e poi l'avvocato nostra
nicolò calò tagliamo l'avvocato ma
perché il tuo è rigido e mia moglie
perché secondo me il tuo è un po più
maturo tagliamo 26 una mano si taglia
simari occhio non andare troppo in
profondità prima che ti tagli un dito
poi mettiamo sopra di avocado no sempre
a sopra centralmente sì anche sopra ok
completamente è un mezzo giro
hai visto è un mezzo giro così più
dell'intero mezzo e poi più stringi
stringi è come se pinza bravissima
vendevi fare un altro mezzo così me ne
enza tu vai continua la rotazione pinza
e arthur j
ma ci sei riuscita mezzo riuscita
riprendilo può adesso fai lo
stritolamento del rol stringe tutto
quello che c'è dentro
ok così dall'esterno verso l'interno
stanno verso l'interno top
ce l'ho fatta
si taglia sempre in otto pezzi gli diamo
con un tocco rapido con un tocco rapido
per centrare forza italia
e allora preferivo la pace della suina
questo è molto molto difficile così
perché vabbè vabbè ragazzi la prima
volta che c'era salmone che faceva
attrito così allora devi fare delle
leggi che certi problema altro salmone
visto me l'avete truccato non si taglia
è difficile mio secondo più falco
scommetti che tutti facile bene vado
bene vado
allora eccola il mio trattamento
sicuramente più bello però ci abbiamo
provato stato gravissima da io ho messo
anche l'avvocato qui sopra che molto poi
prevenzione fa fashion e visto che mi
piacciono le sfide anche se non era in
programma lo facciamo un altro roll
ormai solo lanciata però però visto che
abbia fatto una semplice facciamo uno
super prof
esatto e cosa possiamo fare adorerei
adorerei quanto tu ami
l'oro nero direi che il tema può essere
quello armato di nola chiamiamolo
chiamiamolo alza posso foro adoro oro
vai sono carica
ok allora è tutto pronto siamo per
creare il mio primo roll
ma passiamo subito a elencare gli
ingredienti così capiamo cosa ci
mettiamo dentro allora per prima cosa
utilizzeremo il nostro riso al nero di
seppia secondo ingrediente una cosa che
io amo card passo di gambero rosso di
mazara ne approfitto per salutare tutti
gli amici i mazaresi
poi abbiamo polpa di granchio
questa cosa nuova di uova di lompo che
sono rossi fittissima d'ora questo
colore e foglie d'oro e dei fiorellini
appena volti cosa ci serviranno così
cellini lo scoprirete dopo iniziamo
subito baila andiamo sempre il pugnetto
di riso lo mettiamo al centro e
cominciamo a stelle ormai sono livello
pro dopo di ciò
dopo di ciò io direi che mettiamo in
camper in tempura mari volevamo elencati
negli ingredienti ed ente segreto totoro
io li amo li amo da morire così con la
con la codeina che esce moricola così da
un lato e dall'altro nate dall altro per
mettere un po di philadelphia
adorerei allora parentesi diciamolo la
philadelphia non è un ingrediente che si
trova nel sushi insomma già pubblica può
né io né radizionale però hanno europei
ci piace so che anche voi quando andate
mangiare sushi prendete sempre il roll
con entrati a destra e quindi un po più
occidentalizzato diciamo esatto per i
palati nostri ora prenderei andiamo
200gr vecchia allora mettiamo un po di
philadelphia in mezzo
poi li facciamo il nostro padre mentale
che prima mi è venuta bene adesso
vediamo che devi chiudere bene
all'interno i due mezzi giri top ci sono
riusciti anche stavolta
wow resto perchè c'è questa lingua ricca
c'era quella riga
adesso arriva la parte divertente perché
bisogna bella la tua patria quella di
tagliare roll che bello nome de biasi
poi bravissima ma secondo i granchi un
po più facile allora poi lo impiantiamo
andiamo con l'impianto mento i piatti li
ho scelti io
guardate che top aperti 12
io posso farli così certo ognuno deve
esprimere la propria creatività come
meglio crede allora andiamo a mettere la
tua adorata tartare di gambero rosso
utilizzare top come la mettiamo
io lo ammetterebbe con le mani in cinici
certo quanto riprendo prendiamone un
mezzo pugnetto e chiama sopra il
bellissimo vero bravissima uova di lompo
uova di lompo che pesce solo un po
spolverata vediamo una spolverata
aggiungerei un po di polpa di granchio e
dove la mettiamo sopra il gambero rosso
di sicilia
il penultimo tocco che è quello di
decorarlo con i fiorellini quei famosi
fiorellini che vi abbiamo fatto vedere
prima sopra mammamia quel lavoro
certosino ma guarda che bel poi mamma
mia molto bravissima bravissima e
vogliamo concludere a e vero manca il
tocco il tocco finale da marina da
marina proprio vai oro allora olis
cesare vero amore sì allora basta vorrei
quindi le foglioline
comunque eletto a usare con il sushi è
un po difficile questa cosa tra l'altro
a cosa bellissima e che con insomma solo
super sottili e quindi sembra che si
muovono ora questa sembra una farfallina
top che cadono foglie d'oro
allora io direi che questa volta anche
io come trattamento sono andata meglio
rispetto a quello di prima bravissima
guarda che meraviglia
abbiamo un vulcano di colori e
soprattutto è ad oro a donori toro a
livello come dice estetico mi sento
molto ora presentatosi questi colori
allora lim piattamente top c'è venuto
bene tutto però cioè cosa facciamo non
assaggiamo dobbiamo pure giudicare e
quindi io giudicherei switchando c
quindi io provo il tuo e tu provi il mio
cin cin
horstmann buonissimo allora devo dire
che il roll e adoro è vero senso della
parola piace un sacco
fatemi sapere con un commento qui sotto
se il video vi è piaciuto e in quale
mestiere vi piacerebbe che mi cimentarsi
nella prossima puntata
se non l'avete ancora fatto iscrivetevi
al canale per non perdere tutti i
prossimi video e seguitemi su instagram
tic toc facebook ma seguite anche rosi e
che ha un profilo in st granoche
pubblica tutte queste prelibatezze sud
queen of sushi yokohama che lo scriviamo
qua sotto vi mandiamo un bacione
ci vediamo alla prossima puntata e
[Musica]